what's going on guys this is rob and i
don't really have an outline for this
video just kind of shooting from the hip
here but recent video footage came out
or at least the the little clip right
that we saw that basically reveals
captain carter and doctor strange too
and in reality i mean am i wrong in
saying that i feel like we all kind of
knew that was the case to a degree uh
the captain carter just disappearing
into the multiverse and then eventually
coming back at the end of uh of what if
episode one that we all kind of knew
maybe something like that was happening
i mean my thought at the time was that
it had something to do with the captain
britain corps which i really wish was
true and
in reality could be a missed opportunity
uh but what i think this could do is
actually build up the idea of the
illuminati being bigger than what it is
right so here's the thing about this
when it comes to the illuminati in in
comics and i think most people probably
know this by now just either from our
discussions or their own research or
other youtubers or what have you that
historically speaking the group has just
been like a super clandestine
organization operating on earth in the
comics and that was it um it wasn't
until uh hickman's avengers the new
avengers god i love this story it wasn't
until we got to that story that we
basically ended up seeing like different
versions of the illuminati across the
multiverse and that there were like
different people who were composed who
composed that team who made that team up
which was really really cool
what's going on guys
this is tim you guys know me tim right
like rob's twin uh don't let rob know
that i hijacked his video he's gonna be
pissed
i know you guys like me more than you
like rob anyway he's upstairs right now
just working on you know like remodeling
the house and stuff like stairs have to
be redone and like he just finished
putting down like flooring and stuff
like that upstairs everything but uh
he's just doing like finishing touches
but uh but yeah i know you guys like me
better i like you guys i like you guys a
lot too you guys are cool
okay but i i do i do want to show
we gotta be quiet i do want to show you
guys
something all right check this out
okay so i came into the kitchen so we
could be a little bit louder um
but yeah i think i think we can get away
with it so here's here's the thing
here's the thing right so we have this
integration that we're doing for a
company called scentbird and uh these
guys are amazing all right check this
out
okay so scentbird is this the
subscription service for like colognes
and stuff like that it's like 16 bucks a
month and they have like 600 different
brands which are nuts i don't even know
they existed but like as soon as i
learned about it i was like yeah i mean
like me and rob will do the integration
but like uh i'm signing up for this
right so so here are the three they sent
us they sent us mail and gets which is
an interesting name uh tommy bahama
which honestly i think that one smells
the best and then kenneth cole which of
course are the three i think it smells
the best but kenneth cole intensity is
the the other one they sent us and i
mean they're not they're not like tiny
little sample sizes that you get from
like the mall like these things are huge
right like you literally twist the top
there's a spray thing and then you twist
it back down but like the biggest
problem with cologne man is like when
you buy those bottles they're like these
just enormous ass bottles that you have
to keep in your closet
like we've just been carrying these
things around
like literally because like cologne
fades over the course of the day right
it's like you just spray a little bit
back on you don't want to go crazy but
like you spray a little bit back on and
you're good but yeah for like 16 bucks a
month you get to just choose different
fragrances and they hooked us up with a
coupon code so basically you get like 55
off in your first month so instead of
being 16 bucks it's like seven bucks uh
but yeah like we use it man and we
absolutely love it yeah like this
company's legit man so
like i signed up for it it's pretty
solid make sure you guys check the
description in the video but yeah so uh
you guys excited for doctor strange too
right like we're excited for doctor
strange too movie's gonna be amazing oh
[ __ ] i think rob i think rob's just
about done okay look
just i don't know if rob ever tells you
guys this but like
the dude loves you guys he absolutely
loves you guys like he's it's it's like
he always talks about his fans he's just
like these fans are like the most
amazing fans ever and all that kind of
stuff like i love running geek culture
explain like these fans are so cool uh
he loves you guys he's a softy don't
don't don't let rob trick you into
thinking that he's like a hard ass or
anything like that like
he's gooey on the inside anyway uh yeah
okay he's back he's almost on his way
back
nothing just
chilling
watching some youtube videos
all right he's on his way back down uh
i'll catch you guys later peace
but here's the thing like it's entirely
possible this could just kind of be a
building block right like what if the
illuminati is simply just one facet of a
larger hole that's basically it right
like like a governmental organization
for example like take for example the
secret service here in the states right
only a very small percentage of the
secret service actually operates as the
presidential detail the rest of it
basically deals with like counterfeit
like counterfeit money and different
things like that they work for the
treasury department and so it's entirely
possible like that's the case here with
the illuminati that it may be one of
those things where i wouldn't really
call it a red herring i would call it
kind of the tip of the iceberg right
that like what marvel's showing us with
the illuminati as a team is like this is
only one part of the equation and
there's something much bigger than that
right what if it's like all these
different organizations that have
existed historically in marvel comics
throughout the multiverse that are
either operating under the illuminati
itself or the illuminati is simply like
a special branch of it so take for
example like like peggy carter right
captain carter that she is by all
standards of measurement whether they
want to call her that or not captain
britain in the emcee or at least in that
what if that whatever universe that's
basically what she is right i mean they
could they could call her anybody else
if they want to but she's basically
captain britain that's essentially what
she is right she is a british character
who is playing something akin to the
role of captain america albeit with
british insignia i think it'd be
different if in the what if episode she
was literally captain america but just a
chick right so like had the american
flag on her shield and all that kind of
stuff but like you look at her and you
look at someone like brian braddock in
marvel comics and it's like yeah she's
basically captain britain and that's the
thing like anybody who plays the role of
captain britain they're not confined to
being a captain america-esque character
for example there was a version of
spider-man that was that was a captain
britain in his universe so it's one of
those things where like anybody can play
that role uh that may very well be what
the mcu is doing but say for example
that's the case that still leaves room
for the captain britain core right like
whenever it is that peggy carter is not
meeting with the the illuminati she's
working with the captain britain corps
and like that's basically it when you
have like reed richards fingers crossed
played by john krasinski because again i
still haven't seen the movie yet i'm
waiting to see it just like all you guys
right i'm going to see it the day that
it releases and i am so hyped there's
this amazing taco joint right next to
the movie theater so i'm going to go
there probably get some drinks and then
go see the movie i'm going to have a
damn good time going to see it but say
for example here that uh that reed
richards right played but hopefully
played by john krasinski that you have
the council of reeds and like being on
the illuminati is kind of like his thing
so what are the illuminati's like the
tip of the iceberg they're the ones that
kind of run the show and like the
council of reads operates as a facet of
the illuminati and like the captain
britain core operates as a facet of the
illuminati that would make perfect sense
because what it means is that group is
now a stand-in for what is in effect the
omniversal magistrates right the
omniversal development court that kind
of a thing right we i don't know if
we've talked about that before here on
the channel but for those of you guys
who don't know the multiverse is a huge
and varying place in marvel comics and
you got all kinds of stuff that goes on
in there right you have like altezza the
custodian of the multiverse who was at
one point a guy then it became a chick
who was raised by gamora and adam
warlock uh you have all kinds of stuff
that goes on there right the cosmic
entities and the universal church of
truth which exists in different
universes but sometimes operates on a
multiversal level although it's only
ever happened in like one story i think
uh and even then i'm not 100 sure the
story with protege basically but like
you have a lot of stuff that goes on
right the the captain britain core and
the council of reeds and so on and so
forth
but what you also have as a part of this
is the omniversal development court that
their job is to quite literally keep an
eye on the timeline and make sure at
least in the comics anyway that every
universe has its own like avengers and
x-men and so on and so forth so say for
example that uh across the multiverse
someone will say give or take 500 years
that mutants are supposed to start
popping up at like i don't know 10 000
bc right that's when mutants are
supposed to start emerging and we kind
of use the main marvel universe as a
baseline there because that's when
celine first emerged he was like the
first mutant and the first uh external
to ever exist uh and so so say like
that's the baseline so at 10 000 bc a
mutant somewhere is supposed to develop
in the multiverse and they're supposed
to just kind of go forward and then they
will lead to a proliferation of the
mutant population which means more
mutants will start arriving over the
course of time say for example there's a
universe out there where that doesn't
happen the omniversal development court
would be like okay what's going on there
now i'm not saying the illuminati would
do that specifically i mean the real
question we have to ask here is like
what's their purpose right what's the
purpose behind their existence is it
just fan service is it just like hey
guys we know you guys have always wanted
to see them here so we just arbitrarily
wrote them into the movie and we're
going to kill them all off before it's
done i have no idea
if that's the case i mean usually the
mcu doesn't do something without having
a very particular purpose in terms of
why it's done and it's always been that
way captain america shield showing up in
iron man was a precursor to the arrival
of steve rogers that thor's hammer
falling in new mexico was a precursor to
the arrival of thor unless they're
killing off villains there's usually a
reason why they do something to kind of
set the stage for something else later
along the line and it's entirely
possible this could just kind of be a
little bit of a teaser like this idea of
the illuminati out there that one of the
theories that we had somewhere along the
line is like xavier will basically drop
this idea to stephen strange that like
i'm not the only version of myself like
like we as the illuminati we're not the
only versions of ourselves in the
multiverse right we're not like the
living tribunal we're like there's only
one of us right there's only one of me
xavier in the multiverse and there's
only one baron mordo and only one reed
richards that we are simply just one one
version of ourselves across the whole
multiverse your universe stephen strange
has its own version of me and just like
boom xavier exists in the mcu like in in
the main marvel cinematic universe right
segue into mutants like that's one of
the theories that we had somewhere along
the line whether that proves to be right
or not i i have no earthly clue but
that's potentially something that could
be they could be building up to i don't
necessarily know if that's the case
again we're literally swinging for the
fences here we got like a week until the
movie comes out all bets are off on
theories man i don't even care
i'm gonna throw out the most insane ass
theories that you guys have probably
ever heard that are just that may very
well be so far-fetched that it doesn't
matter one bit right because at this
point i'm just excited man we got a week
until this movie comes out and dude i'm
man i'm getting my man i'm getting hyped
just thinking about it right now
i'm getting so excited but back on the
idea of the illuminati this this is the
one thing that i can't escape that just
i can't let go of
why are they there and and if you know
even if we do get a reason why they are
there why those particular people now it
could just be something where it's like
i mean why not i mean why not those
particular people i mean i i don't know
right but why like why maria rambo why
reed richards why professor xavier is it
just fan service right i mean it's kind
of going back to that for a second is it
really just fan service is it just one
of those things where it's like i mean
we own the fox properties now might as
well put them somewhere and uh and maria
rambo just seemed like a really cool
character to throw in there and so you
know there it goes and then charlie
xavier of the x-men who's basically
lou seems like he's his 1990s version
from x-men the animated series which i
would absolutely love he just comes
rolling out there and is in his little
yellow yellow hovercraft thing that we
saw in the little the little tv clip and
then it's just like he's totally bald
right and he's almost got those evil
looking eyebrows you know and it's just
any and he just talks like like xavier
like the the xavier we expect i would
absolutely love that probably wearing
the green suit that he always wore like
i'd be really excited about that moment
that would be absolutely dope if that
was the case uh but again like like why
those individual guys why those
individual people is it just one of
those things where it's like they are
really part of a greater whole that they
they operate as their own little thing i
mean is it one of those where it's like
they're the antithesis of the tva right
i mean we know at the end of loki that
like kang basically runs the tva now and
if all the information that we've got is
100 true insofar as loki and all that
kind of stuff then basically the marvel
cinematic universe and the multiverse as
it was shown to doctor strange was
separated away from the entirety of the
multiverse so kang has always been out
there he's always been out there in the
multiverse doing his thing we just
didn't know and it wasn't until the the
sacred timeline right that little small
group of of universes merged with the
rest of the multiverse the kang was just
like the tva is mine and like he
literally just overtook it right that
was basically it i mean it's think about
it from the perspective that like king
the conqueror was king of the british
empire and he who remains was king of
like america at the time right 13
colonies that were just isolated away
from the british empire and that
essentially somebody ended up taking out
he who remains and kang was like mine
now and he literally just conquers the
13 colonies and that's it right i mean
maybe that's you know looking at
everything that happened with loki sure
that could very well be the case that
the illuminati's existed for years for
eons and eons neons and maybe it was
just different people who eventually
replaced them the organization is older
than the people who are part of it and
they've always been at war with king
it's just kind of been that way for the
longest time it's been this ongoing war
across the multiverse that's been
happening for quite some time and it's
only just now that we're becoming aware
of it because it's only just now that
we're becoming involved in it because
for all that time we were separated from
it and so it's like kang and the tva are
like they're like the autobots and
decepticons right they're like christina
aguilera and britney spears in the 90s
right nsync versus backstreet boys dogs
and cats living together mass hysteria
like i have no idea
if that's the case i think it'd be cool
i think it'd be a ridiculously amazing
revelation right where literally you
have that moment in the little voiceover
segment in the tv spot where professor
xavier is talking to stephen strange and
he's like let's find out what kind of
doctor strange you are now on the
surface it could be one of those things
it's like well let's find out what kind
of man you are right but to me it sounds
more like we've met a lot of doctor
strangers so let's see if you're
different from the others that we've met
before and just kind of go from there i
don't know right i have i have no no
real idea but i think it would be
amazing if the illuminati like this
current roster of the team is only the
newest iteration that that literally the
team's been around for for just eons and
literally they're waging a war fighting
a war against kang and have been doing
it since
some time after uh king had won the
multiversal war as far as like that
greater section of the multiverse no
clue like it's it's just i don't i don't
know i mean at this point i'm just
excited man like this it's like this
giant mystery right i mean i just i
don't know i love talking about these
crazy theories and different things like
that like i always say i don't care if
i'm right or wrong i know people like
want me to be right or to be wrong i
don't care stop focusing on who's right
or wrong when it comes to theories just
go back to the days of having fun but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end uh i am excited to
see this movie and i will catch you all
later
peace